tla
the lead attorney
uh
you know we gotta have diversity i'm
trying to think of a white one it's not
coming to my mind i'm kidding uh
if it's manosphere it's like okay oh uh
anthony dream johnson
who's that
anthony
i'm the president of the manosphere
anthony
21 studios let me let me look hold on 21
studios
i don't i don't know if i know
i might sometimes i know people's faces
i know i feel you this guy
no
okay
he looks like a woke boy 21 studios
anthony is his middle this is not going
to age well it's okay anthony train
that's him you know him come on
uh not really yeah you do i don't think
i've ever he's doxed everybody in the
sphere okay yeah i don't know who that
is but i'll i'll do it like i'll put
we'll i'll put him in the three you know
yeah yeah okay uh so who else did i say
tla okay him or jack murphy
jack murphy
um he was just on you are here
jack murphy
this guy yeah
um okay that's oh this one's like my
eggs this one's easy um
if you knew the back story on
adj
i think you would think otherwise
i don't pick it
no oh my gosh no the lead attorney i
would marry
okay um he's he's so cute actually yeah
and then
this guy
i would probably f and then
this guy i would kill because okay you
gotta be specific anthony dream john i'm
sorry anthony dream johnson
and jack murphy you flipped it you
wanted to kill him no i wanted to kill
this guy no
but i don't i don't know though oh
god i just this the other guy was
younger like he's better looking no
hair i'll show a goat that's is it not a
good picture it's bad ones okay